hi everyone thanks for tuning in
today's serverless expedition takes us
on a journey to learn more about
google's serverless platforms including
the differences and similarities between
them right wes
that's right martin and thanks for
inviting me to help folks understand a
bit more about app engine cloud
functions and cloud run are you all
ready let's go
[Music]
so normally on this show we only focus
on one of google's serverless platforms
uh why are we talking about all three
today wes
good question martin today's discussion
is broader and doesn't address a
specific use case it leaders may want a
broad but technical overview of our
platforms
users new to google cloud are curious
about how to run apps in the cloud
without virtual machines or kubernetes
comparing and contrasting our platforms
give people a better understanding of
their similarities and differences not
to mention you don't have to worry about
picking the right one from the start
since you can switch between them wow
those are good reasons but i'm not sure
we have time to cover all that how are
you going to do it oh you're absolutely
right about that today we're focusing on
the platforms and their use cases but
the big reveal will be a special app i
wrote that you can deploy to all three
platforms with no code changes that
sounds pretty exciting oh definitely but
you're right in that we won't have time
to go over all of those deployments
today
maybe you can invite me back for an
extended episode so i can show deploying
this app to app engine cloud functions
and cloud run you're welcome back
anytime with but the sooner the better
we wouldn't want to keep everyone
waiting right absolutely
cool now tell me about serverless on
google cloud
the first one is google app engine this
is our app hosting in the cloud service
now why does app engine exist many years
ago our product team want to ask
developers worldwide what they need from
us and they told us all these little
brown boxes were the things that slowed
them down from deploying an app around
the world
they wanted things like machines being
taken care of the database being taken
care of oh by the way make it
auto-scaling as well and make it
available in different languages that
are supported and give us a local
development server and also give us
bundled services like a database caching
external tasks and storage and by the
way
only charges if our app is actually
running
and so they took those little brown
boxes and created a big large box called
app engine made available in lots of
different languages and boom that's app
engine and here's your python mvp or
minimally viable product it's made up of
just three files this is the world's
smallest web app and once you have these
three files and you've downloaded the
google cloud sdk you can run the gcloud
app deploy command and in under 60
seconds your app will be available
around the world at a predetermined url
that we give you our next product is
google cloud functions this is our
function hosting in the cloud service
now why does cloud functions exist well
maybe unlike app engine maybe you don't
have an entire app maybe you just have a
small little bit of code that you want
to have executed
and you don't want to worry about having
web frameworks like a lamp stack or a
mean stack you don't want any kind of
stack you just have a little bit of code
that you want running these could be
little utilities they could be large
monoliths that you've broken up into
multiple microservices or event driven
tasks
now like app engine cloud functions can
be triggered with http but cloud
functions can do a few things that app
engine can't and those are bolded for
example background events you can
actually kick off a cloud function if we
receive a message on cloud pub sub our
message queue service or if somebody
uploaded a file to cloud storage or if
someone logged into firebase
like app engine however cloud functions
is auto scaling and highly available and
you're also only paying for when your
functions are being called
now you can also develop on the command
line like app engine but cloud functions
allow you to do everything from the
cloud console you can create your cloud
function code your cloud function deploy
it and test it all from the cloud
console if you wanted to develop and
test locally we also have the open
source functions framework for you
lastly i wanted to mention that there is
an alternative product called cloud
functions for firebase firebase is our
mobile development platform and
typically if you were going to do more
mobile development you would be using
the cloud functions for firebase but if
you're doing more cloud development or
using more cloud services you'll
probably just stick with regular google
cloud functions but i just wanted to
bring up that there's two similar
products all right and here's your
python mvp for cloud functions it's a
one line function
no config files and because of that the
command line is a little bit longer so
instead of just g cloud app deploy its g
cloud functions deploy followed by the
function name
uh the language that you're using as
well as how this function can be
triggered and just like with app engine
in under 60 seconds typically your
function will be available around the
world at a specific url that's been
predetermined you can either hit it with
curl or hit your browser with http
our last one is google cloud run this is
our container hosting in the cloud
solution
now over the past 10 years containers
have become quite popular one of the
things that makes it a unique feature is
that it supports any language any
library any binary because it's a
container you determine the operating
system you know you load everything in
it that you want and you know for
serverless use cases sometimes those
restrictions uh you know are things that
you can't work around for example you
saw with app engine and cloud functions
there's you know a limited set of
languages that we support but maybe you
have a c plus plus imaging library um
you know that's one of the reasons why
you would have containers because we can
support all of those uh docker's been
around for a long time so you have a
huge ecosystem of base images and really
it's now become an industry standard
and giving you that flexibility that you
really need now one thing that can't be
ignored is many times users just love
the convenience of serverless however
some of the trade-offs are a little bit
more challenging like maybe we want to
use c plus plus or how can we use
binaries and sometimes when you use
serverless platforms you're using the
apis that go with those platforms and
now it's not as easily movable or
portable to other platforms so you
really don't want to feel that locked in
you know that feeling of being locked in
um you know and the thing that people
often uh asking is why can't i have the
flexibility of containers along with the
convenience of serverless
with cloud run because it's a
container-based system you can have any
language any library any binary
the only thing we ask of you is leave an
http port open to us and also make your
app stateless so that if your app is
called multiple times it's not going to
have any side effects on your data once
you have that bundle everything into
container using your familiar docker
commands or the google cloud build
command what happens is that will
trigger a build of your container image
it will put the image into the registry
and once it's in one of the registries
you can deploy to cloud run either fully
managed or through gke
now one other feature that cloud run has
is that it supports get ups this is the
ability to have cd push to deploy from
git i'll give you links to the
documentation and the announcement but
if you also want to mix in tools like
github actions you can also roll on some
ci as well and so the main advantage
here is that once you do you know a git
commit followed by a git push that can
trigger you know running all of your
test cases and then ends up building a
container image and then deploying to
cloud run now one of the last things
that you should know is that there's a
new feature called cloud build packs
where if you use that knowing docker
having docker files or any knowledge of
containers at all is optional all right
here's your python mvp for cloud run
you'll notice that this app is almost
identical to the app engine example
except for the last couple of lines
which are sort of grayed out now with
app engine and cloud functions a web
server is given to you by those
platforms but because we now have a
container it's up to you to actually
bundle the web server inside your
container but just in case you forget
the last two lines of code down there
will start the flask development server
in case you forget so other than that
this app is exactly identical to the app
engine one and uh we have a lot of quick
starts that you can see in different
languages and you can get them at the
quick start link that you see on the
screen
all right
one more thing the docker file so
typically
when you're building containers you
would have a docker file of course you
should also have a docker ignore so you
don't bundle extra files into your
container that you don't need once you
have your code ready to go
you can build your container image with
the g cloud build submit command and
that will take that uh build that
container image and stick it into the
registry and once you're done
you can deploy to cloud run with the
next line which takes that image in the
registry and deploys it up to cloud run
or you can be lazy and combine both
commands with the single line command
that you see down at the bottom which
does exactly the same thing
and just like with app engine and cloud
functions in under a minute your app
will be available around the world at
the predetermined url that you see on
screen
as mentioned on the previous slide cloud
build packs makes it so that you don't
have to know anything about docker or
have a docker file or having knowledge
about containers
it's really optional now
and before we get back to the main part
of the presentation i wanted to present
to you just a list of common use cases
for all of our platforms now this is a
very subjective list but typically these
are what i've seen other users and
different customers have used with our
platforms
it used to be the case that we only had
app engine and that was our only
solution but now that we have a more
complete suite of products you could
pick and choose which
product is right for you and your needs
as the host of serverless expeditions
i'm already familiar with our platforms
uh but that was a pretty useful summary
uh but what about that special no code
changes needed app
that's right it's a small app that
implements a minimal google translate
from english to spanish the app prompts
for the text to translate calls the
cloud translation api to do the hard
work then displays the results in the
browser let's take a quick look at the
code at the heart of the application is
the translate function here it is in
python and node.js where you can see
when users hit the app the first time
its get request returns a blank form to
enter the text they want translated when
the form is submitted the post request
passes the english text to the api where
the resulting spanish translation is
returned
finally whether get or post data or no
data the template is rendered to the
user along with another blank form for
another translation of desired the rest
of it is all the supporting code you
know the imports constants and web
server stuff the most important thing is
that the app runs on app engine cloud
functions or cloud run without any code
changes anyway it's all in the repo so
check it out there
cool app worse but i wouldn't go out of
my way to write an app that runs on all
three platforms why did you do it well a
customer wrote that they had an app
engine app and wanted to call the cloud
translation api from it but couldn't
find the exact instruction in the docs i
wrote it as a proof of concept but also
because i wanted to learn how to call
cloud apis from serverless then i
thought if it runs on app engine it
should also work on cloud run
finally since it's a one function app
that should be a natural for cloud
functions
ah that makes sense as i was wondering
why
i really like that you introduced all
three platforms and letting folks know
they can't make a mistake and pick the
wrong platform that's right pick the one
that matches your use case and if you
determine later that it's not right you
can later switch if you code it in a
flexible way like we did
another goal of this app is to show how
straightforward it is to call cloud apis
and one day non-cloud google apis from
serverless
sounds good i know we don't have time to
see any deployments but i'd like to see
how the app works can you demo it
locally on your machine
yep no developers can run it with
express or flask for python users once
you've cloned the repo or downloaded the
zip file you can test the app locally
node developer should go into the
node.js folder then install the
necessary packages with npm install
after that has completed you can check
out what's there then use the gcloud
auth application default login command
to set the credentials for calling the
cloud translation api from your machine
now run express locally with npm start
and you should be good to go
python developers will do something
similar
cd into that folder and run the pip
install command to get the necessary
packages
when that's done run the same gcloud
auth application default login command
for setting credentials
you can confirm the files look good then
start the flask development server by
running main.py
regardless of which version you run
bring up localhost 8080 in your browser
and translate some text
express doesn't output anything unless
you install some middleware but flask
does output requests when received and
you can see that in the console
cool demo i'll take a look at the code
when we're done but can you give me a
heads up on what we're doing next as
promised listen here are all the
supported deployments in the follow-up
video i'll walk through deploying this
sample app to app engine cloud functions
and cloud run in both python and node.js
we'll do as many of them as we can time
permitting so stay tuned for that
in the meantime here's a link to the
repo so you can get all the code samples
as well as all the codelabs guiding you
through each of those deployments today
great thank you everyone for watching
today if you have questions for me or
watts or suggestions for future episodes
please let us know in the comments below
see you on another serverless expedition
soon
[Music]